The Walking Dead put its characters and
its fans through thick and thin over a
decade so now that it's all over what
was it all really about
the final episodes of The Walking Dead
put the ensemble cast at Center Stage
characters continue to grow and develop
Eugene and Max exposed Sebastian and his
mother Pamela's disdain for the people
of the Commonwealth yumiko shun's
respectability to stand by her friend
and Daryl steps into the position of
Father Figure for Judith at the same
time father Gabriel rediscovers his
faith after taking an almost sadistic
turn earlier in the season while Connie
and Kelly speak truth to power at every
turn the Commonwealth was always going
to be a deconstruction of class politics
rearing their ugly head even as the
zombie apocalypse raged but the series
found a way to deliver a message of
solidarity resistance and power to the
people in its final episode
another major theme of season 11 was
standing by your family no matter what
and the way that loyalty creates a
feeling of home even for a crew being
attacked from all sides for instance
Daryl and Leah originally Bond over
their shared isolation with Leah holed
up in a cabin in the woods that Daryl
stumbles upon and his solo travels Leah
is a tragic figure a loner looking for a
community while Daryl stands with his
found family I would have died for Carl
you know he and Leah are opposite sides
of a coin Leah chooses to follow a
corrupt leader which is a pattern Daryl
also fell into during his early
appearances now with people who care
about him he's able to make things right
Leah however lacks that support and is
lost
similarly Negan is one of the series
scariest villains having killed both
Abraham and Glenn while very nearly
breaking Rick in the process after
spending a lot of time much of it in
prison with the people of Alexandria
he's still convinced he's an eternal
Outsider but after finding love and
family with Annie Negan seems like a new
man he's even able to make amends to
some of the people he hurt back when he
was a big bat he admits to Ezekiel you
are better than me and if you think I
don't know that
then you haven't been paying attention
invasion of the Commonwealth by a zombie
horde inevitably means losing some long
time fan favorites that includes Luke
who he met in the ninth season as part
of Magnus crew though the comics see
Luke dying during the war with the
Whispers he avoids that fate in the TV
series Luke leaves for Oceanside with
his girlfriend Jules in the 10th season
along the way they run into Aaron Lydia
Jerry and Elijah who advised them to
avoid Oceanside at all costs anymore
Luke is reunited with his former
traveling companions but the reunion Is
tragically brief when the walls of the
Commonwealth are breached Luke has to be
torn away from jewels as she's devoured
before his eyes he too sustains major
injuries and parishes in the struggle
despite his friend's attempts to save
him after realizing that there's nothing
they can do they say goodbye yumiko
pulls out Luke's harmonica and presses
it into his hand telling him that he
always brought music to their lives this
is a major callback to their early
appearances on the show and makes it
clear how much they've been through and
grown to depend on each other even when
far apart watching Daryl evolve from a
young man whose loyalties are divided
between his toxic brother Merle and
Rick's crew into the gruff but tender
Lone Wolf he becomes is one of the great
Delights of The Walking Dead Daryl may
prefer to work in solitude but he's
developed a sense of community and
family over the years that was
impossible to foresee early on with Rick
and Michonne out of the picture season
11 sees him stepping more into a father
figure role for Judith there's one thing
I know
there's a whole bunch of people back
there that do anything for you even as
Daryl attempts to protect Judith she
makes it clear that she has no intention
of sitting on the sidelines and insists
on being included in the journey back
into the Commonwealth Daryl reluctantly
agrees to let her come along but regrets
it immediately when they are ambushed
and Judith is shot by Pamela though
Judith pulls through it's only through a
transfusion of Daryl's blood in what
could be a throwaway line Daryl mentions
that he knows he's a universal donor
he released to make me sell it when I
was a kid for money this makes his
gentleness and Care toward Judith all
the more touching as we remember the
world of confusion and pain Daryl has
endured to find his real family carol
foreign
happy ending too
Rosita started as a supporting character
and evolved into a woman able to hold
her own with series stalwarts like
Michonne or Daryl when we meet her in
the fourth season she's involved in a
deteriorating relationship with Abraham
if you're lost please just tell me
Crossing this tank is worth
which then
he moves on with Sasha later she has a
brief affair with Sadiq followed by a
surprisingly healthy relationship with
Father Gabriel with whom she raises a
daughter Coco it's her commitment to
being a good mother that defines her
adventures in the last season as she
becomes a full-fledged Action Hero
starring in some top-notch zombie melees
along the way Rosita Zen is devastating
I'm right behind you her heroism and
willingness to put everyone ahead of
herself sees her bitten and slowly
transforming throughout the final
episode still this season was a boon to
Rosita fans she stepped up with Daryl to
defend the Commonwealth never mincing
words about where her true loyalties lie
when we first met Rosita Eugene had an
unrequited Crush that took Seasons to
resolve but in the end he's the one who
stays with her he's the last face she
sees cementing their status is one of
the most endearing and genuine
friendships this side of Carol and
Darrell
the final episode of season 11 has to
move fast to fit in everything set up in
earlier episodes one of the most vital
arcs is that of Mercer a loyal soldier
of the Commonwealth he appears at first
to be humorless and unflappable until we
see princess's unique charm loosen him
up a bit Mercer's loyalties are in
question throughout the season his duty
to the people is in direct conflict with
his love for his sister Max who becomes
a Public Enemy after revealing Sebastian
and Pamela's callous attitudes towards
the people they're meant to serve yet
Mercer turns around in the end and
proves that there are positives to
standing by one's convictions rather
than becoming a tool of a fascist State
he shifts loyalties and takes the troops
with him when it comes time to hold
Pamela accountable he is at the front of
the group and when she calls him a
traitor he turns the tables on her you
disappeared hundreds of citizens led the
dead to our doorstep
shot a child
the Central Drive behind season 11 is
the importance of placing faith in
people rather than institutions or
politicians and nowhere is that Arc
better embodied than through Mercer a
man who refuses to live life following
orders he knows are unjust
no character in The Walking Dead has had
it particularly easy but Aaron and Lydia
have truly gone through the ringer Aaron
lost both his husband Eric and his lover
Jesus he saw his wish for a better
future for Alexandria dashed through
Lance hornsby's Lies Season 11 has him
experiencing his own dark side only to
turn things around through his
mentorship of Lydia likewise traumatized
by her years as a pawn in Alpha's game
surrounded by death and hate Lydia is in
desperate need of support and family
when she comes to the Commonwealth and
Aaron is one of the primary people to
offer it perhaps more than anyone Aaron
has always been able to put hope and the
desire to serve his friends and family
at the Forefront and that selflessness
has played a major role in his
relationship with Lydia loss is
inevitable
it always has been he encourages her to
take every moment of Joy she can find
with Elijah Annie coaxes her through the
loss of her arm while reflecting on his
own loss you'll feel it sometimes
like it's still there
recognizing his own hope and pain in
Lydia he reassures her you are so loved
The Walking Dead examines what makes a
true leader Rick occasionally slides
into rhetoric which is directly
challenged by Michonne when he's at the
end of his row while Negan commands
total loyalty in those he leads his
ruthlessness makes him vulnerable people
have genuine faith in Rick's ability to
show mercy and ultimately turn to him
over Negan again and again those who
gain power through cruelty are knocked
back down it's an optimistic view of
humanity despite the violence of
villains like Pope the governor and
Alpha King Ezekiel loses his realm to
the saviors but he remains a man of the
people regardless of what occurs always
willing to step in and help wherever he
is needed be it as a decision maker or a
helper Ezekiel has proven himself to be
a true leader Time and Again by never
letting his ego get the better of him
when the going gets tough he leads a
group of prisoners to Shield Negan with
their bodies despite their shared
animosity that's the kind of selfless
act that makes him co-leader of the
post-melting Commonwealth alongside
cursor
the final episode of the 10th season
here's Negan presents a full Focus
flashback of negan's life before he
became the terrifying leader of the
saviors though this was meant to flesh
out negan's backstory and give some
context for atrocities to come the
episode occurs in the context of
Maggie's return to Alexandria as she
presents an immediate threat to his life
if you stay here she will kill you
I just didn't want your death on my
conscience
one of Megan's greatest crimes is the
murder of Abraham and Glenn in front of
their friends which ultimately causes
Rick to shatter when he is nearly forced
to mutilate his son Carl as Glenn's
Widow and the mother of his child Maggie
has not had an easy time with Negan
Glenn was beautiful
I never love anyone like that again
though negan's actions are unforgivable
Maggie knows she's going to have to
depend on him going forward which forces
her to accept his attempts at making
amends perhaps most importantly the
series finale saw Negan finally
apologize after years of wrongdoing he
never fully understood what he'd taken
from Maggie when he murdered Glenn but
his relationship with Annie has
profoundly changed his Outlook I am so
sorry
for what I took from you
one of the best things about The Walking
Dead has always been its expansive cast
however one of the most frustrating
aspects of the show is the impossibility
of giving so many top-notch characters
their time in the Sun the finale
struggles to wind up dozens of plot
threads and character arcs in a very
short time span and while it mostly
succeeds some of it's still just a
little too brief for example after a
stellar character Arc in the first part
of the Season yumiko takes a back seat
in the finale while her romance with
Magna is rekindled their story remains
severely underplayed with only a handful
of moments throughout their three
seasons on the show Connie and Kelly had
Stellar moments in the 11th season
particularly but we don't see much of
them here father Gabriel's goodbye to
Rosita is heartbreaking but far too
brief for a relationship that has lasted
multiple seasons and changed both
characters in fundamental ways Elijah
makes it to safety but we don't know how
characters are what made The Walking
Dead great and we're left hoping this
isn't the end of of our favorites
in episode 1 of The Walking Dead Before
anyone knew it would become a cultural
Milestone we meet a lonely scared man
named Rick Grimes who wakes from a coma
and is horrified to see what's become of
the world around him little girl
I'm a policeman
little girl
Rick is saved by his ability to find
Community with others then nearly lose
them again and again due to hardship
hostile forces or his own ego at one
point with hope for the future at an
all-time low he declares that we are The
Walking Dead
with the final one year later sequence
in rest in peace one of the series most
shocking turns is the promise of a
challenging future but also an
underlying sense of hope I want to talk
about the future there's a lot out there
to find out about and I think it's time
we did it's wild to watch a series Once
mired in its own Bleak Outlook morph
into something optimistic but that's
exactly where the series finale leaves
us
thank you